der Magellansche Strom droht mit unserer
Galaxie zu kollidieren ein gewaltiger
Gasstrom der uns viel näher ist als
bisher angenommen genau das haben
us-wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler jetzt herausgefunden und
so droht unsere Heimat Galaxie
möglicherweise eine Kollision mit diesem
gigantischen Bogen aus Sternen und Gas
und eine andere Kollision mit unserer
Galaxie hat dagegen bereits begonnen
klicksum science and future hier gibt es
drei Mal pro Woche spannende science
Videos abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert
die Glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen das ist diesen
ungewöhnlichen Strom aus Gas zwischen
der Milchstraße und den beiden
magellanischen Wolken gibt das ist der
Fachwelt schon lange bekannt doch
bislang wusste man nicht wie nah uns
dieser sogenannte Magellansche Strom
wirklich ist seine aktuelle Studie
offenbart jetzt die große Überraschung
fünf mal näher als gedacht könnte uns
dieser riesige Gasstrom wirklich sein
möglicherweise eine Gefahr für unsere
Heimat Galaxie Milchstraße denn das Gas
könnte mit ihrem Halo also dem Halo
unserer Galaxie wechselwirken und später
könnte es sogar zu einer gewaltigen
Kollision kommen genau davor warnen
jetzt die us-fachleute in ihrer
aktuellen Studie alle spannenden Infos
zu diesen neuen spektakulären
Erkenntnissen gibt es jetzt hier bei
Klicks und Suns and future die
Milchstraße die Galaxie in der wir leben
ihr Durchmesser beträgt unglaubliche
hunderttausend Lichtjahre und sie setzt
sich aus bis zu 300 Milliarden Sternen
zusammen es handelt sich um eine
Spiralgalaxie Fachleute haben Sie unter
anderem deswegen noch längst nicht im
Detail verstanden denn ihre Gestalt
macht es äußerst kompliziert die
Außenbereiche der Milchstraße genauer zu
analysieren daher sind die
Zusammensetzung der Milchstraße und auch
die Ausdehnung ihres Halos bisher nur
teilweise erforscht mit dem Begriff Halo
meinen Fachleute das was sich rings um
die Scheibe die meist als die
eigentliche Galaxie betrachtet wird
befindet es handelt sich um eine
annähern sphärische kugelförmige Region
in der Kugelsternhaufen und sternströme
ihren Platz haben genauso wie eine Menge
an Gas Plasma und wohl auch die
mysteriöse dunkle Materie sind im Halo
von Galaxien zu finden all das gehört
also zum sogenannten gravitativen
Einzugsgebiet einer Galaxie bei dem Halo
handelt es sich also um eine Art diffuse
Hülle immer wieder werden neue Studien
veröffentlicht die überraschende
Erkenntnisse über unsere Heimatgalaxie
offenbaren so konnte mit der Höhe des
röntgenteleskops xmi.m es vor kurzem
festgestellt werden dass der Halo der
Milchstraße wohl heißer und eisenärmer
ist als bislang angenommen dazu die
us-wissenschaftlerin Samantha Barrick
von der Yale University sie berichtet
die riesigen Halos und Galaxien zu
verstehen ist enorm wichtig denn diese
reservare enthalten den Rohstoff für
künftige Sternbildung in der Galaxie
aber auch die ausströme von vergangenen
Ereignissen wie super Norway der Halo
ist daher voller Informationen über die
Vergangenheit und Zukunft einer Galaxie
zudem verrät die Ausdehnung des Halo
einiges über die gravitative
einflussfehler einer Galaxie doch jetzt
berichtet eine aktuelle Studie
spektakuläre Erkenntnisse über die
Nachbarschaft unserer Galaxie konkret
geht es um den sogenannten
magellanischen Strom
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
Rätseln schon seit vielen Jahren wie
dieser gasausstrom entstanden sein
könnte klar ist allerdings dass uns
dieses Gas einige Hinweise auf die
Geschichte den ur und das Schicksal der
großen und der kleinen magellanischen
Wolke geben dabei handelt es sich um die
nächsten beiden Nachbarn unserer
Milchstraße nicht nur die Milchstraße
sondern eben auch die magellanischen
Wolken sind in ihrer Vergangenheit wohl
mit kleineren Zwerg Galaxien kollidiert
vor drei Jahren hatte ein
us-forschungsteam herausgefunden dass
die magellanischen Wolken möglicherweise
einmal Teil einer Dreiergruppe von Zwerg
Galaxien gewesen sein könnten doch vor
rund drei bis fünf Milliarden Jahren war
die dritte Galaxie wohl mit der
magellanischen Wolke kollidiert und
zerstört worden Hinweise darauf
lieferten nicht nur eine Gruppe verkehrt
herumkreisender Sterne in der großen
magellanischen Wolke sondern auch ein
mysteriöser Ausbruch der Sternbildung
zum möglichen Zeitpunkt dieser Kollision
eine spannende Geschichte also die die
Nachbarn bislang miteinander erlebt
haben sie stehen also in enger
Wechselwirkung zueinander und zudem auch
mit unserer Heimat Galaxie der
Milchstraße die
schwerkraftwechselwirkung führt nach
Ansicht von Astronomen und Astronomen
weltweit dazu dass es immer wieder
Diebstähle gab die Nachbar Kunden sich
gegenseitig nicht nur Gas sondern auch
Sterne der magellanische Strom aus Gas
und Sternen verbindet die beiden Wolken
miteinander und ist fast so lang wie die
Milchstraße sein Ursprung und auch sein
Alter bleiben bis heute rätselhaft dazu
sagt der US Astronom Scott luccini der
Ursprung des magellanischen Stroms ist
seit rund 50 Jahren ein Rätsel zwei
mögliche entstehungsthesen wurden
bislang diskutiert wurde der Strom etwa
durch Gas erzeugt dass aus dem Galaxien
herausgerissen wurde als sie durch den
Halo unserer Milchstraße wanderten oder
entstand der Strom etwa durch die
Gezeitenkräfte der Milchstraße
Forschungsteams konnten in der
Vergangenheit zeigen dass der
Magellansche Strom nicht nur älter
sondern auch länger ist als gedacht
möglicherweise hat er demnach sogar ein
stolzes Alter von zweieinhalb Milliarden
Jahren aktuelle Modellsimulationen von
US-Forschern können jetzt vielleicht
auch weitere bisher ungelöste Rätsel um
den magellanischen Strom klären dazu
nahmen sie neuere Daten der
magellanischen Wolken genauer ins vis
diese Daten weisen darauf hin dass die
beiden magellanischen Wolken von einer
Art Corona aus warmen ionisiertem Gas
umgeben sind dazu schreibt das
Forschungsteam Zitat zusammen mit dem
heißen Zukunft galaktischen Medium der
Milchstraße spielen die hydrodynamischen
Effekte dieser Corona eine signifikante
Rolle für die vergangenen Bewegungen der
beiden Wolken kurze Erklärung das zirkum
galaktische Medium ist nichts anderes
als das Halo die Hülle der Milchstraße
die aus Gasen und Plasma besteht hier
sind nicht nur Kugelsternhaufen und
sternenströme zu finden Astronomen
Astronomen gehen davon aus dass es sich
dabei um eine Art rohstoffreservoir für
die neue Sternbildung handelt und
tatsächlich gab es eine Überraschung für
die Fachleute als sie die Corona in die
Simulation einfügten lautes
Forschungsteams ändert sich dadurch die
ganze Orbitale Geschichte der Wolken
demnach haben sich die beiden
Zwerggalaxien vor rund 1,4 Milliarden
sehr angenäht dabei wurde sehr viel
Material aus der kleineren der beiden
Wolken herausgerissen Material für den
magellanischen Strom die aktuellen
Simulationen unterscheiden sich enorm
von dem Modellen die bislang aufgestellt
worden waren denn in der aktuellen
Studie bewegt sich die kleine
magellanischen Wolke plötzlich gegen den
Uhrzeigersinn an der großen Nachbarin
vorbei und so zeigt der Gasstrom ebenso
plötzlich nicht mehr von den Wolken und
der Milchstraße Weg dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen Studie unsere Rekonstruktion
resultiert in einem auf uns
zugerichteten Strom der bis auf 65.000
Lichtjahre an die Sonne herankommt also
das ist schon verdammt nah die
Ausrichtung des Gasstroms ist demnach
also ganz anders als bislang gedacht und
das hat weitere Folgen der gigantische
Bogen aus Sternen und Gas könnte uns
demnach also deutlich näher sein als
bislang angenommen und zwar bis zu
fünfmal näher der Strom liegt laut der
US-Astronomen Astronomen fast schon am
Außenrand der Milchstraße und das hat
Folgen zum einen könnten seine Sterne
von uns beobachtet werden zum anderen
könnte somit auch der Steckbrief des
magellanischen Stroms umgeschrieben
werden denn auch in Bezug auf seine
Dichte und Masse könnten die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
bislang falsch gelegen haben lediglich
ein Fünftel der bisher geschätzten Masse
hält das Forschungsteam nun für
realistisch dazu der us-astom Andrew Fox
der in der Studie beteiligt war durch
die veränderte Entfernung müssen nun
auch einige Merkmale revidiert werden
das betrifft unter anderem auch die
Lebensdauer des magellanischen Stroms
die den neuen Erkenntnissen zu Folge
dramatisch kürzer sein könnte als
bislang vermutet die neuen Erkenntnisse
haben also auch Auswirkungen auf die
Zukunft des Gasstroms und nicht nur das
auch für unsere Heimatgalaxie die
Milchstraße könnte das Konsequenzen
haben denn es droht eine gewaltige
Kollision zwischen dem riesigen Bogen
aus Gas und Sternen mit der Milchstraße
nach Ansicht der forschen steht uns das
allerdings erst in rund 50 Millionen
Jahren bevor doch bereits deutlich
früher könnte es zur Auswirkungen dann
nämlich wenn das Gas mit dem Halo
unserer Galaxie wechselwirkt dazu die
Einschätzung des Forschungsteams der
Magellansche Strom könnte aufgrund
seines annäherungswinkels sogar direkt
mit der Scheibe der Milchstraße
kollidiert eine andere Kollision ist
übrigens bereits im vollem Gange
Kollision unserer Milchstraße mit der
Andromeda-Galaxie hat begonnen hier gibt
es bereits die ersten Beobachtungen
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran